Oracle is a company that we have all
heard about here or there and know that
they have something do it computers and
software but what does Oracle even do
well the company sells database software
and technology cloud engineered systems
and enterprise software products which
has made them worth almost 200 billion
dollars placing them as number 81 on the
fortune 500 list but in the early 2000s
after the.com bubble they actually lost
over 80% of their stock value so how do
Oracle come back and get so big once
again make sure stick around till the
end to find out
[Music]
welcome to Horry salaries so all start
in 1977 when Larry Ellison and Bob miner
- computer programmers at American
electronics and their supervisor at
Oates saw a company called software
development laboratories they were
heavily inspired by the British computer
scientist Edgar Codd he had outlined a
relational database model and these
three saw a lot of potential in it their
goal was to organize large amounts of
data in a way where it was efficient in
terms of storage that could be retrieved
quickly and with that the three astara
developing a marketing program that was
based off cost data management theories
in 1979 the Capri released Oracle which
is the world's first commercial
relational database program what sets
them apart from the competition was that
they used structured query language or
SQL they quickly rose in popularity
starting off with their first customer
the US Air Force the wright-patterson
Air Force Base near Dayton Ohio was her
first customer by 1982 Oracle was so
popular the whole company changed her
name to Oracle they quickly grew
throughout the early 1980s and in 1986
they would go public and just a year
later in 1987 they were become the
world's largest database management
company while Oracle's database program
grew rapidly was actually their
aggressive acquisitions that grew the
company very quickly Oracle would buy a
scores of companies with their most
recent acquisitions including PeopleSoft
Siebel B EA
Sun Microsystems and NetSuite and this
is how Oracle really grew but with the
start of the 1990s
there was a lot more competition and
database market this led to very
disappointing earnings for Oracle and
left a period of restructuring even more
trouble came to company in the mid-1990s
when they made a bad investment in
network computer or m/c Network
computers are computers that use minimal
discharged memory and computing power
they are designed to be connected to a
network which gives them power the idea
is is that business workers typically
don't need all the power of their
computers offer they were trying to
replace business personal computers with
networked computers there was also some
pretty convincing cost advantages as
well as a networked computers themselves
were cheaper than personal computers
from Microsoft plus you can easily
update and modern users to a central
network it seemed like a really good
idea and that it would help grow the
business while taking business away from
the competitor Microsoft but the thing
was Windows computers were getting
really cheap and this really eliminated
the need for networked computers this
unfortunate timing along with other
mistakes dragged the company down and
led to huge losses leave them almost to
bankruptcy they had to layoff half of
their employees and to make matters even
worse they had to restate incorrect
financial statements there had been
overstating revenue and this led to a
class-action lawsuit by this point the
company had lost 80% of their value and
it had to do something different what
they decided to do was stop acquiring
other businesses and focus on their own
main business of databases they soon
released the next generation of
relational databases and this along with
their internet compatibility allowed
them to find success once again
in fact they reached such high Heights
after 80% drop in value in the early
1990s would become unrecognizable Oracle
really started focusing on data based
software applications and this really
made investors very excited about Oracle
while at first it sounds really good
this was actually really bad for Oracle
as it made him a prime victim of the
dot-com bubble if you don't know what
that doggone bubble is it is also called
an Internet bubble and it was a rapid
rise of us technologies to
so due to speculation it was fad based
investing that many venture capitalists
and firms took pardon they poured a lot
of money to technology companies as they
wanted to be part of the next big thing
like Microsoft or Bloomberg and this
phenomenon had a huge effect on Oracle's
growth throughout the late 1990s and
early 2000s let me put it all in
perspective with some oracle stock
prices throughout this time period in
the 1980s oracle stock was 50 or 60
cents and after a missteps it dropped
all the way to about 15 cents now they
did completely change of focus and do
something different now realistically
considered the niche they're in this
could lead to a stock price increase to
a couple of dollars it would be pretty
surprising to reach the $10 mark given
the time and circumstances but with the
help the dot-com bubble their share
price has reached over $40 per share now
compared to lows in the 1990s this was a
25,000 percent increase or 250 times
more for every dollar invested they got
$250 back and this was great news for
Oracle at the time they didn't know what
was actually happening and as a result
they naturally expanded with their
increasing income and this would become
a huge problem when their stock prices
plummeted and the thing is one-day
speculative prices have to crash by
nature that this is precisely what
happened early 2000s when the.com bubble
burst it all started when huge
technology companies like Dell and Cisco
placed large sale orders for their stock
and this is when a stock peaked on March
10 2005 thousand and $48 these huge
corporations wanting to sell their stock
really instilled a lot of fear among
investors investors scrambled to sell
all the technology stocks and within
just a couple of weeks the stock market
lost 10% of its value investment capital
quickly dried up and many companies
completely folded this speculative
bubble seems like a no-brainer today but
when it was happening it seemed pretty
legit we might even be in one right now
I mean shoot goober and we work be value
as high as they are
when they're losing billions of dollars
per year if they turn out to be like
Amazon and become profitable that'll be
an investment of a lifetime but if those
companies fold in ten years it will seem
like a no-brainer to not invest in
companies that are losing so much money
so hopefully that helps to contextualize
why that whole incident happened it
seems a lot simpler in retrospect than
in reality anyways going back to Oracle
their stock price dropped from $45 to
just seven dollars in just two years
their capital had evaporated and they
lost over 80% of their value
once again this new stock price is
probably closer to a true value of the
company and this would ordinarily be no
problem this is still significant growth
from 60 cents a share but the thing is
with all that capital flowing in during
a dot-com bubble Oracle made a lot of
choices that they otherwise wouldn't
have made and where investment took a
downturn the company really took a
beating but they would come back so how
did they come back this time well last
time they really focused on their core
business but this time it would do the
exact opposite they would really focus
on expanding their portfolio and
diversifying their income in 2005 they
would acquire PeopleSoft which was the
enterprise software specialist for ten
point three billion dollars and then
less than a year later in early 2006
they require Siebel for five point eight
three billion dollars and then their
next big purchase came in 2008 of B EA
systems this was an enterprise
middleware and application software
company that they were required for
eight point five billion dollars and
these three purchases really allowed
Oracle to return to her growth
trajectory but their next acquisition is
what would really make them big once
again this acquisition was Sun
Microsystems in 2010 for seven point
four billion dollars they got two main
assets from this acquisition which used
a java programming language and a MySQL
database platform and this gave Oracle
entry into the tech market and allowed
them to compete much more effectively
and then after all of that they went out
and bought NetSuite for nine point three
billion dollars and this has really
bolstered Oracle's presence in the cloud
computing space and why this is so
important is that this purchase allowed
them to expand the revenue into
recurring revenue this has allowed them
to start to move away from fluctuations
in the revenue due to one-time hardware
and software sales with recurring
revenue their overall revenue is much
more predictable and all of this has
really made stock investors very
confident in the prospects of the
company and this has not only allowed
them to return to her speculative
heights but actually be today reaching
$56 in June of 20 n-- Oracle's comeback
is a prime example of a tech company
adapted to new technology trends and
diversifying their business they have
really picked up a lot of momentum and
they don't seem to be slowing down
anytime soon their comeback was really
made possible by their transition and
focus from hardware to software and
service offerings this is made evident
by the rapid growth in cloud computing
and data analytics Oracle's really
taking advantage of the new unique
opportunity by a technology world and
are really pushing the boundaries
forward and of course they are looking
to acquire more companies as our
acquisition of NetSuite is already
starting to pay off
they are playing trying to expand to new
categories and diversify their income
even further they want to make sure that
another devastating experience doesn't
ruin the company and they seem to have
done a really good job as Oracle has
made a full comeback they are stronger
than ever before Oracle is a giant in
the tech world and they have done very
well in staying relevant they have not
let the changing conditions in
information technology make them
obsolete they have made some missteps in
the past and really got burned by a
dot-com bubble which both almost led
them to bankruptcy but today if anything
be said back actually a lot Oracle to
grow it has really taught them to adapt
and this has allowed them to take full
advantage of current tech trends and
they seem to join the industry's growth
prospects for the foreseeable future but
that's all I have for you guys have
Oracle make sure comment down below what
company you would
me to cover next also if you guys like
this video they mentioned drop the like
and consider subscribing if you don't
see more videos just like this one but
till then I'm Lauren I'll see you guys
on next one